millions of Americans as you know are
addicted to opioids tens of thousands
die from OD'ing on them every year this
is the worst drug crisis in American
history by far but there is another
addiction crisis going on that gets no
coverage at all tens of millions
Americans are hopelessly addicted to
their electronic devices specifically to
their smartphones their online video
games and lots of other things that big
tech has gotten rich on it's a big deal
dr. David Hill is chair of the American
Academy of Pediatrics Council on
communications in media and he says that
smartphone addiction is a crisis for our
society dr. hill joins us tonight doctor
thanks for coming on when you say it's
an addiction do you in what sense do you
mean that it's quite an addiction in
that the average person checks the phone
17 times a day but in a clinical sense
is it addictive yeah I don't think
anybody would say that it's addictive
Tucker
in fact the dsm-5 the current
statistical manual that psychiatrists
use specifically carve out that there's
not really a diagnosis called tech
addiction now there are a couple of
diagnoses that they think are worth
investigating and those are problematic
internet use and internet gaming
disorder those sorts of problems are
thought to affect up to maybe 8% the
numbers differ from four percent to
about nine or ten percent of American
youth but whether that's an addiction in
the same way that opioid is an addiction
you're looking at about 116 Americans
killed every day on average by opioids
nobody would rather that cellphones are
killing 116 people a day of course not
but are they degrading our society are
they making it difficult for people to
continue linear thoughts to read books
to concentrate and and I know DSM
definitions change over time would you
say it's a compulsion it certainly seems
to meet that threshold you know anything
that gives us instant pleasure is
something that we can become dependent
on and at the point that we're ignoring
the other needs that we have in our
lives to pay attention and get that sort
of pleasure then it becomes a problem we
deal with children and the biggest
problems that we see in true
children related to smartphone use or
screen use or particularly sleep obesity
there are some concerns about attention
nobody has proven that smartphones cause
ADHD that's a popular theory but the
science is not out there to really draw
that line there has been a lot of
concern about rising rates of depression
and anxiety that are coming along at the
same time as rising rates there's an
author Jean twinge who's worked on that
and her argument is that the phones came
first then the psychiatric problems
so maybe the phones cause the
psychiatric problems but I think more
conservative researchers would stop at
least one step short of that and you're
aware this distinction between
correlation and causality those orders
will see a very strong correlation but I
don't know that most experts in the
field are quite ready to jump to
causality I know a lot about the
correlation between a lack of research
and not really knowing what the truth is
a lot of research on this thing which is
ubiquitous in our society and wasn't ten
years ago I mean I don't know why we
don't know more I guess is the question
we're almost at a time but do you have a
thought on that many of my friends and
co-workers are working on this issue
right now the research is burgeoning but
it takes a while to do a good study and
the technology is moving fast and so
once you get a study in the bag the
technology has evolved right away from
you but I would strongly support more
money dedicated toward research yeah
this is huge
what's changed everything and we haven't
paused to think about how we will doctor
thank you good to see thank you